guys when it comes to eSports or just
about any other form of competition
sometimes it's not enough just to beat
someone in the game sometimes the
situation calls for a little
psychological warfare if you will a
little BM now when we talk about BM in
this list guys we're not referring
specifically to truly toxic moments here
we're talking about those pocket picks
and strats that you only bust out when
you really got a style on someone oh and
speaking of styling if you've still got
a friend who can't spell eSports
properly well we've got the perfect
piece of apparel to remind them how it's
done literally little s ports no - no
[ __ ] s large one little ones and
then if it's at the starter sentence
it's really easy what do you do with a
normal word you can so if you still do
have someone in your life who can't
spell esports properly do them a favor
show them this shirt a link to it will
be pinned in the comment section below
now without further ado let's get on
with it with the top 10 BM picks and
strats in esports starting our list off
is everyone's favorite item from the
csgo gear menu no we're not talking
about armor or even a defuse kit or
talking about the zeus and while
purchasing a zeus can sometimes be a
strategic decision most of the time it's
about sending a message that will tilt
your opponent off the face of the earth
which is exactly what cloud 9 did
against Team Dignitas at Dreamhack open
Stockholm 2015 hauling its high angle
with the zeus this pays off this would
be sickening for dignitize night it with
the teamwork officer bags himself a frog
and i cells use another azuz into town
Wow that's smart move from cloud nine
not to overcome it on this second round
either even though you're up this watch
okay I'm just gonna need their clout
light will pick up the map i'll indeed
the best of three instant kill ticket
it's like a mobile off you know and it's
pretty funny yeah this beloved mildly
psychotic yodel rarely makes an
appearance in professional play and when
he does it's usually by accident
CJ drafting the Devo but coming in at
number nine is the time that hi actually
chose to play teemo in the mid lane it
was against team solomid during the 2014
na LCS super week and while his
performance was far from spectacular hai
did prove that the swift scout could
help secure a legitimate win any
champion listen no no welcome to the
north american LCS on the back draft is
able to take down five oh very nice job
coming out turtle let's up under sneaky
the ad carry drop the ignite takes them
down teemo come out of nowhere and he
gets him with the mushroom he is almost
knocking down five members they don't
want to move they're all magnetically
attracted to him and dyrus is the focus
for cloud nine right now
this could give wild hurt on the rest of
the team enough time to do damage but
cloud nine is just too tanky meteos
coming through the AoE damage picking up
two in a row two big double kills coming
in for high and meteos their error just
absolutely taking everything they can
away from TSM and the wind 17 and now
your first came to the north
number eight on our list comes from the
International 2018 we're Team Liquid
found themselves up a game against vgj
thunder in a group stage match TL had
already punched their ticket to the
playoffs upper bracket and they decided
to save the last pick for miracles hero
Ricky Lawson ending the game with a 16
for 7 stat line miracle unlocked the
full power of a carry ricky tearing
through vgj thunders heroes in dominant
fashion returned the damage Thank You
spike carapace and miracle gets to be
donating 6 3 3 4 miracle that's your
record time from fate they need to keep
that control up and they've got a
witness iPad rider it's delete but
miracle in the back line 2 tons on
tricks of the trade 40 find himself a
double kill and so much information the
observer and century is on the hill back
when they fought last time so it's just
a jump in to kill off the juggernaut
does he fight back into this fight fate
could not push himself far enough up the
hill and then take it on board
it is matumbo I see if mind control hit
scorer everyone's that triple kill for
miracle he doesn't even have to walk
anymore he just rides on the back and
throws daggers of people an old truck
he'll for miracle
Danya PE can be summarized in two words
joke character with weaker versions of
everything Ryu has to offer there are a
few situations in which Dan is viable
and as a character whose gimmick
involves taunts picking him can be seen
as well a taunt itself so that's why our
number 7 spot is reserved for the time
justin wong picked Dan in Marble Madness
2011 s grand final against hair
Justin having some fun here giving it so
real
I don't know I think Justin's just
trying to psyche out there like I said
here's the problem here's that here is
the power of Dan I'm gonna explain this
right now
as soon as Dan is about to win you start
feeling so bad like I can't lose the Dan
I can't lose the Dan and then when you
lose the Dan and that's what's gonna
make you end up losing perhaps no
operator in Rainbow six siege is more
beloved by the community than to chunka
unfortunately that admiration doesn't
come from his viability in competitive
play it's only for when you're beating
someone like 300 and you just want to
rub it in but you're better than them
that's all which is why our number six
spot is dedicated to Lord to chunka
pentas baby and teased a potential
tachanka picked during a pro league
match against c su esports but switched
off to Jager at the last moment but it
was shot a who brought out the turret in
the following round taking somewhat of a
moral victory for his team
I should say you're amazing yolk we have
been teased the tachanka pick twice in
the playoffs so far to recharge and and
and yes their time's the charm shot say
he managed to finally get it out there
shot they will try to lay down some
shots just just pop him a little bit you
know you want to he's gonna go Peggy's
gonna go for this fight Wilke will be
injured from the Waldo last man alive
Penghu is gonna try to go one-on-one
here however KS comes in from the red
hall and takedown shocking guys calling
fnatic rich in the last round of the
first half against Navi at
season one would be an understatement
and what better way to show off your
wealth than to buy five opps with change
to spare in the past fanatic abhi known
to barrage opponents with off shots and
even once bought four ops in an iconic
2015 game against team envyus
when against an awful Asst na'vi fnatic
figured that no man should be without a
sniper rifle proving that five ops are
mightier than none
[Applause]
phonetic I certainly have any grand old
time here the first tiny bottles they've
got 11 rounds on CT side table while the
second pill for blood says ooze crouches
write it for the angle and now do not be
realized what's going on do they start
like did they actually get 5 ops against
us there's no way they all know what
this feels like but how do you get out
from under JW on the other side to pick
it up though aw shucks taking down an
ounce on C's one on three simply out of
luck now me 3 rounds is all they go to
the first - at seat 12 3 on
[Applause]
[Music]
per 4 on our list comes from the 2015
lck summer finals SKT were up 200 in a
series and it was fair to say that faker
was feeling pretty good about himself
faker after all is the greatest League
of Legends player of all time and was
known for his ribbon play but few were
expecting him to blind pick her in a
grand final
but even Katie's Cassiopeia counterpick
couldn't help them as faker went on to
dominate the lane securing both the
morale and championship victory oh yeah
Kenan supported Baker is going to be
bringing his Riven to the mid lane once
again both coming in double six they get
the flash from not a faker comes in he's
got the oh he's got the kill beautiful
be a dinner of SKT dodged that
petrifying haze so beautifully I almost
couldn't see it let's watch this one
again let's see how faker the wait for
the animation comes down
beautiful ribbon mechanics things Baker
does and bang is going to win champion
for his team SK Telecom three Oh in the
spring season three Oh in the summer
season this is the year of SKT csgo is a
game with a plethora of viable
strategies but most of the time they
don't involve buying the gebbs or crab
walking with duley's but at our number
three spot an IP pulled out the secret
strats against alternate attacks at Star
Series season 9 turning an otherwise
uneventful map into one of legendary
status yeah that's one two a third one
picked up is it going to be more more
negative with another one the neck of
strategy reign supreme before rank is
going to be finally taking down four
five Joe Bereta they have no respect for
this just devil watch Crouch play I love
this
well well we'll see how this is gonna
run fold they're gonna keep walking
exist he's he's gathering the troops
right behind him I shoot them back he
gets the crouching crab duel elites they
do no work out Christmas the runner up
on our list comes from the 2014 world's
quarterfinal match between Samsung white
and team solomid already up two games
Samsung's Game three draft was
unconventional to say the least
as it heavily focused on assassins with
no waveclear and no intention of playing
the macro game I wonder if their style a
little bit blind picking a Kassadin
where's the waveclear here from Samsung
white are they going to be so much
inside
jungle of GSF that they don't even
consider wait clearly way pushing from
Jack I'm a threat like you're gonna have
five teemo's and it will be stronger
together than this cop they have just
built Samsung believed they could run
over TSM with their superior mechanical
ability alone they will wrong with a
more standard game plan
TSM managed to hold on and win the game
against the Korean powerhouse but they
have to be able to punish this comp from
Samsung wife Cathy one of the weakest
mid laners early game and moto one of
the weakest tough lateness and because
center white has no way clear daddy's
not even there with the team he's
topside I can't try to get this Kassadin
going is the only way to Central and to
get back in the game the hideously poor
early game Cobb Samsung white is picked
give TSM the belief and factual
knowledge that they can defeat Samsung
white just a few more shot all very low
a cleanup crew is sitting on the rift
right now if they can't take that
partner and
in a preview of what ended up being the
TI six grand final wings faced off
against digital chaos in an earlier
upper bracket round having won the first
game of the series the Chinese squad
decided that game two would be a good
time to draft punch though the match was
short-lived winds showed they were not
feeling the pressure that comes with
competing in a multi-million dollar
tournament with one of the most
ridiculous drafts in TI's storied
history this is wings you don't know
what to expect expect the unexpected if
anyone was gonna pick techies at the
main event it was always going to be
waged if anyone was gonna pick Pudge it
was definitely gonna be them they also
have ways to scout the putt he's in
trouble
defensive disruption is not there in
time and then he leaps in Kenny co-op
resolution she's a bit sweet baby's
gonna come to resolution I think in the
hook them up the ghostship arrow missing
I could have been the Lunas death maybe
they get blue on top of the lines he'll
stay alive states of trap and he will
fall the go ship coming through allowing
them to push even further and that it's
overbought the wings get stopped
sometimes you wrap up the first game of
a three-game series and it goes really
well and you think great let's just keep
doing what we're doing sometimes you
think [ __ ] it let's just go Pudge
techies I think it kind of shows genuine
balls to go and do that but I also think
it's absolutely bonkers well guys that's
our top 10 list for this week now the
real BM here is if you don't hit that
like button sub to the channel and check
out the score eSports online merge
Department I'll see you next time thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button